Обмороження кінцівок для безпритульного - це або ампутація , або смерть від подальшого переохолодження.
Рятувати безхатченків на вулицях часто нікому. Нерідко їхні тихі прохання про допомогу ніхто не чує.
Як от цього чоловіка, якому нещодавно ампутували ступні.
Викликай швидку, вмираю...
Спроби знімальної групиDWвикликати швидку, отримати допомогу в медпункті нічим не завершилися.
Чоловіка замість перев’язки  відправили просто грітися в зал очікування.
Підземні переходи на вокзалі та в метро для багатьох безхатченків - одне з небагатьох доступних місць порятунку від морозів і вдень, і вночі.
Навіть якщо в Києві, за офіційним даними, відкриті понад 30 пунктів обігріву, а в кожному районі працюють будинки соціальної допомоги.
Я знаю, що цей будинок соцдопомоги біля вокзалу бере лише по 5-7 осіб для відводу очей та пристойності.
А основна маса - на вокзалі. Я туди прийшов, і мені там морду набили. Тільки ліг - мені кажуть: йди сюди. Ти новенький. І давай мене бити.
Мені 64 роки. Це нормально? І охорона там є !
Я тільки на вокзалі ночую або йду в під’їзд якийсь грітися, де теж голову відкрутити можуть.
На жаль, цей коронавірус вибив з колії багато точок, де можна було отримати ночівлю.
Тому що раніше можна було піти на Гвардійській 2. Там можна жити по 2-3 місяці.
А так на вулиці Жилянській можна прийти ночувати.
Утім, не всі безпритульні можуть добратися до цих комунальних ночівель. Та й не скрізь їх приймуть, особливо, коли немає документів.
Тож головний клопіт безпритульних - мати якомога більше теплого одягу та взуття,
які можна міняти, коли вони, приміром, стануть вологими від снігу.
Волонтери з благодійних та релігійних організацій цими днями роздають на  вулицях Києва теплі речі.
Вони намагаються зігріти безпритульних, готуючи теплий чай, каву, бутерброди та гарячий бульйон.
Тільки тут, на Майдані Незалежності, по кілька разів на тиждень щоразу годують не менше 200 людей.
Деякі організації встановлюють свої цілодобові намети для обігріву.
За оцінками волонтерів, ситуація більш ніж критична.
За офіційними даними, на тому тижні, що були морози, померли там 15, скажімо, людей від морозів і переохолодження.
А за неофіційними даними, півтори сотні померли від переохолодження і невідомо скільком ампутували кінцівки.
Проблема дуже серйозна, тому що мало де є такі пункти, а вони дуже потрібні.
В мене багато інформації, що люди замерзають. Ось в Броварах, мені зателефонували, що вже дві людини на смерть.
А їх, цих пунктів, немає. Тут люди рятуються реально. Увечері повний намет людей. З усього району. Їм жити ніде.
Їм або лізти в підвал, або сюди погрітися та поїсти. Тут роблять ще і перев’язки.
Як виживати взимку на вулиці, волонтер Євген знає не на словах - він і сам прожив просто неба цілих два роки.
Це я 2 роки тому. Я п’яний. Ось, лежу на Дарниці на ринку. Я вже помирав, відчував, що вже все, кінець.
У сильні морози чоловік приходив ночувати ось сюди - у колектор біля Дарницького вокзалу.
Теплопункти, колектори, теплотраси  - місця, де намагаються пережити морози багато безпритульних.
Однак ці місця часто стають останнім притулком таких людей.
Там трапляються пожежі, можна отримати сильні опіки через прорив труб або заснути і не прокинутися через відсутність кисню та спеку.
Ось, тут відкривалося і туди залазили по сходах . Там труби і на трубах лягали.
Там багато усілякого сміття, так ось на смітті і спали. Я по собі пам’ятаю, що чотири доби вилізти не міг.
Просто лежав, спав, бо не було сил. Бо спека суцільна.
Людмилі Андріївні69 років, вона - з Закарпаття. До столиці свого часу приїхала брати участь у Помаранчевій революції.
Каже, планувала залишитися в київській квартирі матері, але майно з причин, які жінка не пояснює, опинилося в чужих руках.
Тож уже 15 років Людмила Андріївна живе на вулиці і добре знає, як виживати в колекторах або теплопунктах,
які вона особисто вважає найкращим варіантом в ситуації, коли немає грошей на хостел або паспорта для комунальних будинків соціальної допомоги.
Жінка пригадує, як одного разу не з власної волі провела під землею цілий місяць.
До одного з  улюблених об’єктів зайшла і  чую, що замочок закрили. Ага! Ось мені буде випробування!
Думаю, прийдуть знімати покази хоча б раз на місяць. Тоді мені требе все, що в мене є, поділити на місяць.
Десь купляла "Мівіну". Ага, в мене три "Мівіни". Потім ще в кишеньках такі шматочки сушеного м’яса, стіки з цукром, сіль, плавлений сирок.
Я розділила на місяць. Тобто декілька грамів кожного продукту.
10 різних асортиментів: сіль, часник, імбир, всього потрошечку було.
Людмилу Андріївна врятувало ще і те, що на "своїх" об’єктах для ночівлі вона зазвичай робить запаси води.
Свій теперішній притулок вона показувати не хоче, каже, що соромно.
Натомість залюбки показує, що навіть у центрі Києва, де усі підвали зайняті офісами та рестораціями, де в дворах охорона,
є місця, де все ж можна облаштувати собі тимчасовий притулок.
О-о-о. Навес з дровами, килими. Ось, бачите, є місця.
Ти нікому не заважаєш. Там зробити собі дерев’яні планочки, розкласти. Картону дуже багато люди викидають.  Ага…
Бомжі страйкують, бо зараз телевізори пласкі, а раніше можна було в цій коробці з-під телевізора жити.
А зараз коробочки такі, що туди не влізеш.
"Колеги" Людмили Андріївни (так жінка називає своїх друзів-безпритульних)  вважають її "експертом з виживання".
Колись жінка працювала в рятувальному загоні на Закарпатті, займалася спортивним орієнтуванням,
тому завжди може знайти тимчасовий притулок, аби перечекати негоду.
Під балконом  на сухій землі. Якщо пощастить, можна натрапити на от-такі "дружні до безхатченків" під’їзди.
Можна шапочку висушити. Зігріваю руки.  Тихо, спокійно. Як добре!
Життя - це рух. Якщо не рухатися під час морозів, можна загинути. Такий принцип сповідує Людмила Андріївна.
Вона пересувається Києвом здебільшого пішки. А ще намагається не хворіти, бо грошей на лікування в неї точно немає.
Запевняє, що свої часті бронхіти вилікувала пірнанням в Дніпрі.
Скоро три роки, як ні кашлянула, ні чихнула. Кажу, не можу просто простудитися, з такою тривогою.
Так організм втратить спосіб боротися з застудою!
Позитивна Людмила Андріївна - радше виняток з правила.
Більшість безпритульних аж ніяк не можуть дати собі ради.
Жінка розповідає, що в результаті пандемії на вулицях опинилося багато заробітчан, які втратили і роботу, і житло.
І це не лише українці з інших регіонів, а й іноземці, особливо з країн Азії.
Точних даних щодо кількості безхатченків у Києві немає.
У 2020 році КМДА звітувала про 280 офіційно зареєстрованих.
Але, за даними волонтерів, незареєстрованих безпритульних від 5 до 10000 і більше.
Цьогорічні морози навряд чи всі переживуть.
Тобто ми маємо ситуацію,  коли мають бути рятувальні бригади, рятувальні програми.
Категорією мислити порятунку людей і, безумовно, ще і гідності.
Це мають бути пункти, де тепло, де є туалети, де є провітрювання приміщення.
Не знаю, чи варто вживати слово "безпритульний" чи-то "бездомний".
Тому що, по факту, це просто люди, які опинилися в небезпеці через морози.
Волонтери закликають владу розробити відповідні програми допомоги, просять киян не бути байдужими.
Людмила Андріївна не очікує допомоги.
Жінка дбає не лише про себе, а й, чим може, допомагає своїм " колегам" , які пересуваються на милицях або хворі.
Привозить їм одяг, ліки, які купує на гроші від вторсировини, що здає, продукти, які викидають супермаркети або кияни.
Калина з медом. Можна з'їсти, можна подарувати.
За рівнем сміття можна оцінити рівень життя. Кажуть, тяжкі часи.
Я можу задати кожному питання: "Коли ви останнього разу штопали одяг, білизну?"
Іноді Людмила Андріївна, причепурившись і купивши найдешевший квиток, навіть відвідує вистави та концерти.
Виявилося, що вона обожнює філармонію. Цей концерт - "Музика кохання" -  вона відвідує на честь свого дня народження.
Каже, що музика допомагає їй трохи забутися, відійти від інколи занадто жорстоких реалій життя,
відігріти від морозу не лише тіло, а й душу.